it's the Sam Simon in its crew that are
confronting the issues here
head-on of course their days with a bit
frustrating when you see this
overwhelming amount of nets that's out
there that there's still the fishermen
going out and laying more nets the Sam
Simons primary weapon in their fight
against these gill net is what they call
a phantom Ray Ray set four seven eight
meters the way he's dropped into the
water at a set depth and drags a
grappling hook along a sea floor
when the hook catches a net a thin
breaker line attached to the ship snaps
this releases the Ray and marks the Nets
location with a boy I reckon there's a
couple of - twelve are in the water
there there must be six seven carcasses
of 212 our floating buyers right now I
guess the deal is that they cut the
bladders out as quick as possible
and throw the rest in the sea are we
gonna launch the boat and go find out
whether it is a turbo net or a long line
or any illegal fishing gear these in his
waters and then we're gonna retrieve it
come with it
of course the sea Shepherd team who've
managed to scoop up the rebels of that
now
we're on our way to find out what's in
it surrounded by dead carcasses of the
12 have been mutilated
swim bladders taken out there everywhere
one two well is tougher yeah but it's
Wamba a far from the only victims of
these nets and the nature of the sea
there could be anything in this neck we
have been finding everything from sea
lions to dolphins to hammerhead sharks
we saw not too long ago we saw a wailing
was like like almost like an hourglass
for how much the net was strangling the
the whale like halfway through so it
really is a whole lot of species that
are caught up in this trade for the
trataba right like the net doesn't
really distinguish who is gonna catch so
whichever animal swims through through
these waters is is sentenced to death oh
gosh IRA
oh no I'm ahead
Oh Chris it feels pretty stuff is still
alive
we're wiping out sharks from our oceans
for their fins in Asia they eat shark
fin soup and what happens is that a lot
of fishing vessels catches sharks cut
their fin and then throw back their
bodies and finding a dead shark that
hammerhead in in these nets is really
it's really heartbreaking but a
heartbreak here isn't reserved for
marine life alone as the Sam Simon
continues its mission to remove illegal
gill nets the nearby fishing towns
suffocate
[Music]
Oh